in the age of digital marketing it is
very easy to get lost in the sea of
information
if you are a beginner you will probably
spend a lot of time reading and
researching even if you are an expert
you will still need to keep up to date
and know what's going on in the
marketing world but how do you find the
time to do that how do you find the time
to stay on top of trends and innovations
we have compiled a list of 20 plus
digital marketing tools to help you make
your life easier
some of these tools might sound familiar
to you and some might sound new and
interesting we believe all of them have
some value in your life and can assist
you in staying on top of trends
hey everyone i am tushar bharival
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
in this video we will understand 20 plus
digital marketing tools to grow your
business in 2022 but before we begin if
you enjoy watching tech related content
consider subscribing to our youtube
channel and hitting that bell icon to
stay tuned
so without any further delay let's get
started with the plan for today's
session first we will look at the
research part next we will explore tools
to build or host a website
content is king so next we will have a
look at some of the best content
creation tools to grow your business
moving forward we will discuss designing
and graphics tools once designing is
done it's time to promote and hence we
will look at the best promotional tools
after that we will discuss some great
email marketing tools user behavior and
computer analysis tools and finally we
will end the session by understanding
the communication tools that will help
your business operate smoothly
research research is one of the most
essential parts of getting your business
to the next level it's what turns an
idea into a real business however it is
hard to do research without the right
tools luckily there are many tools out
there that do the job perfectly here are
just few that you need to know about
uber suggest uber suggest is a free tool
that produces fresh keyword ideas it is
among the best free tools available on
the market however it has a premium plan
for advanced features but it is best if
you are starting out and it has some
good features like you will get the
search volume for free keyword ideas and
content ideas
keyword planner it is one of the best
free tools and the best part is that
it's a google product so that the data
can be trusted you can use google
keyword planner to do keyword research
google keyword planner will show you the
monthly search volume of keywords and
phrases the average cost per click in
your selected country and how difficult
it is to rank for the keywords some of
the best features
are you will get the custom time-based
keyword data and get to know the
competition on that keyword
hrefs hrefs is one of the most advanced
tool available for keyword research it
is also used for competitor analysis
rank tracking and site auditing
hraf's main features are geared towards
marketer but you can also use it to find
keywords for google youtube and amazon
the tool is paid but suitable for
businesses looking for in-depth
information it has some features like
rank tracker that will help you know
your existing website ranking and the
second one is alert you will get
important information or stats by mail
after doing the research part you need a
website for your business let's have a
look at how to do that the first step in
creating a website is to find a place to
host it there are many options out there
and depending on what your site will be
used for you may need different tools
web hosting tools have evolved to meet
the online community's need better it
can be challenging to select the right
one through many options here are the
few of the best tools available on the
market
wordpress it will help you create your
website by just drag and dropping
no coding is required also it has a lot
of plugins that can be used according to
your website needs
blogger you can create a beautiful blog
using blogger for free and it is also
has free themes which you can use
still it is always recommended that you
use tools like wordpress to build your
website because businesses need a
website with lot of functionalities and
wordpress makes this process easier
the website requires hosting as the next
tool we have is hostinger you need to
purchase a domain and hosting to host a
website there are other companies also
available that you can use to host your
site such as godaddy hostgator etc
hosting job provides automatic backups
that will ensure that your website data
is secured and allows you to create
unlimited sub domain which is also
necessary for a business website
for free hosting and free domains you
can use infinity free but for a business
website it is always recommended to go
with the paid hosting because this will
give your customer a good experience
when they visit your website
but for a beginner just wanting to learn
how website hosting works you can use
infinity free
every business website and its social
media platform need content and content
is the oxygen of the internet there is
no surviving without it but meeting the
demand of a content hungry world often
means that you are forced to pull your
hair out only to throw more into the
fire
from research to creation to
distribution content is now 24x7 job
requiring many internal resources or
costly outsourced help
if you are looking to cut down the cost
and streamline your efforts here are
some content creation tools to take your
business to the next level
headline it is an ai tool that will
create a landing page automatically new
writing designing and coding is required
you need to give information about the
product and it is also has built-in
templates to use it became famous
because of this feature but now it is
upgraded and you will see a lot of other
features that will help you create
excellent content it is a paid tool but
you can try its free version
paper type it is a one stop ai solution
tool for all content needs and the best
part is you will get 10 000 word limit
to try out this fantastic tool the
specialty of this tool is that it allows
you to create content for specific
social media platforms and long form
content
grammarly grammarly is a free online
tool that find mistakes in your writing
and suggest improvements as you write
grammarly will underline any mistakes
you have made and offer suggestions on
how to fix them
additionally it has a plagiarism checker
and a punctuation checker
however for additional features you need
to go with grammarly premium
the best way to create excellent content
is to have good visuals this is why we
have listed the best designing tools
that you can use to get stock images and
videos
canva you can design your website using
canva for free it is the best tool to
make your website content more engaging
it is a simple drag and drop tool that
allows you to create beautiful graphics
flyers infographics social media posts
and more
you can also use it to create more
engaging images for your posts
furthermore it gives you free templates
and allows you to collaborate with your
business team using team functionality
pixabay pixabay is a free website or a
creative community that shares copyright
free photos illustrations music and
videos
all pixabay content are licensed under
the pixabay license you can use them
without asking for permission or
crediting the artist even for commercial
purposes
you can download these stock images
videos musics and illustration without
signing up shut a stock although it also
comes with the same feature the key
difference is that it is paid you might
wonder why to use this shutter stock
since we already have a free tool like
pixabay well it depends on your business
needs there are some images and stock
footage that you will only find on
shutterstock in addition shutter stock
has powerful editing tools and custom
size options that attract people
now we have a better understanding of
the content part in order to attract
more visitors the content needs to be
promoted the following tools will help
you promote your business drive traffic
to your website convert visitors into
leads build brand awareness etc
google ads google ads are a powerful
tool that can help you reach your target
audience it is small but significant
step towards online success through many
people believe that google ads are not
as effective as they used to be there
are still more benefits than drawbacks
the only thing you need to know how to
use it your website can be advertised
via google ads and your product and
services can be promoted on youtube
it has an excellent feature lead form
extension that allow user to provide
their contact details directly through
the ad without visiting your landing
page
additionally life events targeting for
example graduating from a college is
also a great feature since it helps you
reach the correct type of audience
facebook ads manager it allows you to
run facebook and instagram ads and it's
an excellent way to promote your
business a feature like facebook
analytics will give you a good grasp of
data
feature like audience insight will
better understand who is interested in
your product and services
google ads and facebook ads require you
to spend money on ads by setting up a
daily or a custom budget bussumo is a
content marketing tool to help you find
the best ways of engaging creating and
spreading content across social and
search channels two of the best feature
is finding an influencer that will help
you to find the right influencer
and a content discovery feature which
will help you to discover new content
ideas
email marketing tools are the most
effective means to stay in touch with
your customers you can nurture leads
rearrange with your audience and build a
subscriber base through email
businesses today recognize the
importance of email and marketers are
investing heavily in email marketing
tools
however in the overwhelming sea of email
marketing tools finding the right fit
can be tricky we have selected some of
the best email marketing tools to help
your business get started and grow
through 2022.
mailchimp mailchimp is a comprehensive
marketing platform that lets you keep
track of and communicate with your
clients customers and other interested
parties
but it is popular because of its email
services there is a free plan of
mailchimp the free plan is often more
than enough for small businesses
up to 000 subscribers can be added and
12 000 emails can be sent a month it
supports multiple integration to
integrate other third party softwares
and mailchimp also allows you to update
or remove the subscriber profiles which
is also one of the best feature of
mailchimp
send in blue it is very similar to
mailchimp both have excellent and
similar features when it comes to email
services one unique feature of
sendinblue is that it has an option of a
drag and drop builder that is accessible
by mobile
analysis and optimization
businesses need to analyze and optimize
their processes to grow
furthermore you should analyze the data
to develop a solution to the problems in
your industry
several tools can be beneficial here
let's discuss that
google search console this tool will
help you understand how your website
performs on google searches by ranking
on top you will have higher chances of
attracting more visitors the index
coverage report will help you understand
which web page have problems moreover it
has a very useful url inspection tool
which gives information about google's
indexed page version
vid iq many youtubers majorly use it to
analyze their performance on youtube and
optimize their channel if you are
looking to rank your video on youtube
you need to optimize the title
description and tags this tool helps you
to do that
the tool includes a thumbnail generator
that lets you create customized
thumbnails that generate good views and
it has trend alerts which will notify
you by email of popular content
google analytics using google analytics
you can track the traffic on your
website and find out where your visitors
are coming from
it also allows you to track your sales
performance and traffic sources
google analytics is a tool that will let
you know if your website is performing
well and also if you need to make some
changes to improve its performance
it has outstanding features like funnel
analysis and smart goals a funnel is a
method for determining which steps are
necessary to achieve the desired
outcomes and with smart goals you can
identify and count the most engaged
users on your website user behavior user
behavior tools help you understand user
behavior on the website user behavior
tools are very effective tools used in
digital marketing to track the behavior
of visitors and make the business more
effective
below are the sum of the user behavior
tools used in digital marketing
hotjar hotja is an inside tool that lets
you analyze your customer behavior and
get feedback to understand them better
and come up with new business strategies
to grow your business
this tool gives you visual feedback
which you won't find in other tools and
it also offers surveys which is also a
unique feature of our jar
smart look it is mostly similar to hot
jar but it has some additional features
like customizable dashboard and
conversion funnel which means the
visualization of how people follow the
path
competitor analysis many businesses
start their competitive study when
planning their digital marketing
strategy and then abandon it
it is essential to make adjustments
after competitor analysis and use great
tools here are some of the best
the tool is completely paid you can use
this tool to improve your ppc campaign
as it gives you insight into what your
competitors are doing
keywords can also be imported as well as
downloaded socialblade it is used for
social media monitoring and influencer
tracking for example you can get lot of
information about the performance of
other competitors and how they are doing
on youtube and other social media
channels
the best part is that many features are
available in the free plan
similar web it is also an excellent tool
to analyze competitors website traffic
and you can also get the google play and
apple app store data
href we already covered this in the
research category but we wanted to
mention it here because href will also
be viewed as one of the best tools for
analyzing competitors
communication
starting and building a successful
business require better communication
within your team we must ensure that our
task has been clearly communicated to
the team so that we will be able to
perform the work as we intended thus one
needs a tool to accomplish that so now
let's check out some of the best tools
for communication
slack the app is a chat room that brings
together all of your team's
communication in one place
meaning there is no longer a need to use
email skype or multi-chat room apps
slack can be used with both work and
personal accounts and it can benefit
businesses in several different ways
microsoft teams it is also similar to
slack but it offers unlimited app
integration and unlimited chat messages
there are free plans for both but you
can upgrade if your business needs
aren't met
hear what you have learned so far
initially we discussed research then
tools to build and host the website next
we discussed content creation and
graphic designing tools after that we
discussed tools that will help in the
promotion and then the email marketing
tools after that we discussed analysis
and optimization tools
next we discussed user behavior and
competitor analysis tools and finally we
discuss the communication tools
so with this we have come to the end of
this session
we hope you enjoyed this session about
digital marketing tools
we are always looking for new ways to
help our learners achieve their goals
and this is just one of many ways we do
that
please feel free to leave a comment
below with any other questions or
concerns you may have and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve your queries at the earliest
until next time this is tushar from the
simply learn team signing off thank you
stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here